moving on our main story tonight
concerns computers there's one in my
house one in my pocket and one on my
wrist and fun fact if they all broke at
the same time i die
more specifically we're going to talk
about the fact that we've all had
unsettling moments when it became clear
that our computer was monitoring our
activities a little more closely than we
might like after financial planner rod
lawrence opened a new office he used a
credit card to buy baby wipes to clean
the place he says after picking up just
one canister he was shocked to be
bombarded with targeted online ads for
other baby wipes and more children's
products something this single guy
around town says he's definitely not
interested in at least not now
yeah it's true poor rod got roped into
the modern update of hemingway's classic
story for sale baby shoes click here and
look of course rod didn't want that [ __ ]
he was a man about town he was only
interested in three things getting laid
getting paid and rocking the hell out of
some wrap around shades
but we have all found ourselves being
targeted by ads for something oddly
specific and thought how on earth did
they know to show me that and tonight
we're going to talk about who makes that
possible data brokers it's a
multi-billion dollar industry
encompassing everyone from credit
reporting companies to these weird
people finding websites that pop up
whenever you google the name of your
friends sketchy new boyfriend to these
names that you may never have heard of
but what all these companies have in
common is they collect your personal
information and then resell or share it
with others as one expert puts it
they're the middlemen of surveillance
capitalism which sounds like both a
horrific profession and also a b-plus
jake gyllenhaal thriller he's not a spy
and he's not a civilian he's the middle
man and ladies in this one he shows
trunk and look
i know it is not news that you get
tracked online in fact roughly six in
ten u.s adults say that they don't think
it is possible to go through daily life
without having data collected about them
by companies or the government making
four out of ten us adults embarrassingly
wrong but this this isn't just about the
convenience and or irritation of
targeted ads data brokers operate in a
sprawling unregulated ecosystem which
can get very creepy very fast
the major u.s retailer officemax knew
not only that mike say's daughter was
dead but how she died it says mike say
daughter killed in car crash
or current business and this is my home
why would they have that kind of
information why would they need that
right and obviously that is completely
appalling but i will say it is not that
surprising to me that officemax was
behind that as they're clearly not
entirely on top of their [ __ ] if you
google officemax right now the people
also ask questions include and this is
true is officemax the same as office
depot
is office max and staples the same and
does officemax exist
the truth is when it comes to data
brokers they know significantly more
about you than you might like and do
significantly more with it than you
might think so tonight let's talk about
the whole industry and let's start with
how your information is collected
basically every time you interact with
society you are leaving little
breadcrumbs that can be gathered
together and sold and much of this
happens online thanks in large part to
cookies cookies were developed in the
early days of the internet and they're
actually one of the things that make it
slightly better a distinction that they
share with henry winkler's twitter feed
and literally nothing else
what they essentially do is enable
websites to remember you they are why
amazon remembers that you put a 106
complete box set of the mentalist in
your cart after eating an unexpectedly
strong weed gummy even if you don't
and if that's all cookies did it'd
honestly be fine but the practice
gradually evolved to invol to include
third-party cookies basically companies
other than the site that you are on
planting a piece of code in your browser
that allows them to track where else you
are going on the internet just watch as
a tech writer explains what they found
when they tried to learn just how many
companies were tracking them
so i started the day on google and did a
search and nine trackers were downloaded
onto my computer trackers do what it
sounds like they do they track you they
can get my ip address or the device i'm
using or the screen size they
were able to determine my location very
precisely next i went to huffpo and i
was swarmed the the trackers kind of
multiplied there were dozens and dozens
and they're just the trackers are just
kind of you know on my heels as i go
around the web yeah and i don't know
about you but i don't want a whole crowd
of strangers watching what i search for
on the internet not because it's gross
because it's private private doesn't
have to mean gross there's nothing gross
about looking up let's say are there any
shower heads with a contains pulp option
i wouldn't want it all the time i
wouldn't need it all the time that's why
it's an option the option to have some
pulp in the shower
it's can i finish
it's a normal shower most of the time
but occasionally i'll have the option to
get pelted with something that's got
some heft to it
just some weighted chunks of whatever
swamp for one flop something to wake me
up and keep me on my toes sometimes i
need it don't claim that you don't we'd
all love to pretend that the sun only
rises in peace time but things being
what they are we find ourselves again at
war so yeah start my day and rock me
with some juicy bits that's what i want
and i don't want anyone watching me when
i search to see how close we are to that
particular technology existing because
it is private
but data brokers often take all the
breadcrumbs that they have gathered
about you pair them with other data they
can obtain and then share all of it with
businesses who want to market to you and
they will frame this as a win-win here
is how epsilon one of the biggest data
broker firms positions itself
this is a person
so is this
here's another
and another they all look and act
different but people are fundamentally
the same
they all want respect protection and an
easier time getting the things they need
from brands
right the big three
it's all in maslow's famous hierarchy of
needs people want their physiological
needs met their safety accounted for and
their search history handed over
directly to the aflac duck
epsilon's ad even goes on to show how
that particular service of theirs works
demonstrating how they can create a
client id for someone that contains
everything they know about them like the
fact they're a vegan and that they make
45 to 50 000 a year or that they are a
41 year old male who is married with
kids at home and is googling snow globe
stuck in but what to do question mark
and once companies like epsilon collect
enough information about you they can
sort you into groups data broker firms
sell access to lists with names like
couples with clout ambitious singles
boomers and boomerangs potlucks and the
great outdoors golf carts and gourmets
and kids and cabernet those are all both
real names of groups compiled by a data
broker and as of now immediately
greenlit shows on tlc
and look you might not care if a company
wants to toss your data in a group
called kids and cabernet so marketers
can more effectively sell you things
that make you seem like a bad mom in a
fun way but
there is also a dark side here because
some companies can and do draw up even
more narrowly targeted lists like people
with certain ailments or sexual
preferences and then sell those lists to
anyone who wants to buy them and what
they can buy is pretty troubling
wreal bought thousands of names and
addresses of local people with serious
illnesses this group living in the 27607
zip code have diabetes these people in
27608
have cancer these residents of 27609
have high blood pressure and all of
these locals battle depression this list
is moms to be so we brought this data
and it and it tells us you're pregnant
yes and you are i am
yeah i am 18 weeks
that's pretty creepy isn't it i honestly
did not think there could be a worse
thing to ask a woman you don't know than
are you pregnant but you are pregnant
want to know who i paid to find out has
certainly entered the chat
and if you're thinking but that's
illegal under hipaa right
well no as one researcher pointed out
the medical information that you relate
to your physician is highly protected
but
if you go to a medical website and
search for terms like hiv or abortion
that information is not protected at all
it's a system that seems ripe for abuse
before you learn that some data brokers
have offered lists such as suffering
seniors payday loan central hispanic or
even help needed i am 90 days behind on
bills and some in this industry will
insist that they would never put people
at risk by selling their data remember
epsilon the company that collects clouds
of information about you in 2014 their
then ceo even went on 60 minutes to
reassure people that his business in
particular operated in a completely
above board manner if there are abuses
out there we don't believe those happen
within our company and we would be the
first to raise our hand oh really you
would be the first to raise your hand
would you that is interesting especially
because last year epsilon settled with
the doj for 150 million dollars for
facilitating elder fraud schemes after
admitting that it sold more than 30
million consumers data to clients who
employees knew were carrying out scams
and they were doing it for nearly a
decade so i guess that that guy really
should have been doing that entire
interview with his [ __ ] hand in the
air
and at this point you may be thinking
okay
i think i get it i am sufficiently
creeped out there is nothing more that
you need to tell me well hold on
what about the fact that apps on your
phone can give away your exact location
to third parties sometimes without you
even knowing it this free flashlight app
settles with the ftc for doing just that
and they are not alone take life360 an
app giving families the opportunity to
keep track of one another you may have
seen their ads featuring parents looking
relieved because they can see where
their kids are going and know when they
have safely reached their destination
well guess what in a report from the
website the markup says that life360
sells its location data to about a dozen
different brokers who then sell it to
marketers yeah it turns out they were
selling location data to around 12
different brokers it's like those old
commercials it's 10 o'clock do you know
where your children are because if so
same
and i have to tell you live 360 insist
that they are no longer doing that and
anyway they had de-identified their
users data before selling it that last
claim is actually very common among both
data brokers and the companies that they
work with and it is worth taking a look
at because while it sounds reassuring
the truth is it can be incredibly easy
to find out who is behind a number or a
code one team of researchers even found
that 99.9
of americans would be correctly
re-identified in any data set using just
15 demographic attributes among them age
gender and marital status and the ease
of de-anonymizing data is something that
we have actually known about for years
in 2006 aol turned over a bunch of these
anonymized search records of their users
to the public and it only took a few
short hours for reported decode who user
number
4417749 was between searches for things
like numb fingers 60 single men and dog
that urinates on everything the reporter
uncovered a woman named thelma arnold
she was age 62.
okay i'm not saying that it is at all
pleasant that that happened but for the
record i am glad that it introduced me
to thelma arnold because i love that
woman she hasn't given up despite her
numb fingers lackluster love life an
utterly broken dog none of that is
stopping her from shooting her shot and
looking for single men in her area
we stan a middle-aged queen with stamina
as we looked into this story we
constantly got reminders that none of us
are really anonymous online at one point
a researcher clicked on this company's
website didn't do anything else just
went there on his browser and later that
day got this email saying that they knew
he visited and that we offer a pretty
cool service called website visitor
identification which helps brands
identify who's browsing their website in
fact it's how we knew how to send you
this quick email
which is just objectively unsettling i
don't want anyone tracking what my staff
members are doing online mainly because
i don't want to know how many of them
have looked up what is john oliver like
and
it is not like data brokers are super
careful about who gets your sensitive
information you have already seen a
local news station ambush a pregnant
woman and a few years ago cbs bought
some location data from brokers and it
did not take much for them to find out
whose it was where they lived and what
they were doing no names or phone
numbers were tied to the data but it was
easy to figure out who each phone
belongs to based on where they spend
their nights here in greenwich one phone
pinged in the morning inside a seven
million dollar mansion the person then
visited a country club before heading
downtown and returning home yeah that
doesn't feel great does it although i
will say that particular example is not
that surprising to me if you told me an
individual woke up in a 7 million
mansion in greenwich connecticut and
made me guess where they went next i'd
have gone with i don't know um
a country club
downtown to hunt humans for sport and
then home again and i'd have been pretty
sure that i was right
and the thing is that kind of
identifying information can cause huge
problems just last year a priest was
forced to resign after a catholic
newsletter said it used app data signals
from grinder to monitor his activity and
matching his phone to his residence
essentially outing him which is a
massive harmful invasion of privacy and
definitely the worst scandal ever to hit
the catholic church
also just quick side note here catholic
church are you absolutely sure that
jesus was homophobic think about it he
had mutually respectful friendships with
women a distant relationship with his
father and when he found out he was
going to be betrayed he invited everyone
to a confrontational dinner
i'm just saying it might be worth
re-examining your thesis there
and look you might still think i don't
care about this my life is an open book
i have no secrets so data brokers can
just have at it
even if that is true for you though
consider that there are others out there
who might have very good reasons to not
want to be found
donna is a domestic violence victim
we're protecting her identity one of her
addresses came up on a data broker site
she says that's frightening if you have
someone that's
tried to kill you
for them to be able to just type in your
name and any known address that you've
ever stayed in
can pop up
it's scary because now they know ways
to start trying to find you
right and that's not just theoretical it
has happened in new hampshire a stalker
killed a former classmate after finding
her with information that he bought from
a data broker for 45
and if you have a stalker or you're a
victim of domestic violence it is
understandable to want your information
removed from these people search sites
unfortunately each has its own specific
and sometimes very complex process of
requesting the removal of information
and there is no federal law requiring
that they honor an opt-out request at
all and the lack of regulation here
doesn't just benefit individuals who
might mean you harm it benefits the
government too because it gives them a
very attractive loophole to the fourth
amendment protection against
unreasonable searches and seizures
because under that the government
typically needs a warrant to collect
information about you without your
consent
but if it is not forcing someone to turn
over your data if it's simply buying it
from a data broker that is apparently
fine no warrant necessary and you can
see how valuable that would be to them
it happens all the time in fact federal
agencies from the fbi to ice have
purchased data without warrants public
disclosures or robust oversight to carry
out everything from criminal
investigations to deportations and the
thing is you might not know if your
information has been supplied to the
government by an app even the company
behind the app might not know because it
might sell your info to a broker which
then resells it to someone else which
then supplies it to the government i'll
give you an example a couple of years
back vice found that the app muslim pro
which lets muslims know when to pray
have been selling user location data to
a broker that supplied information to
the us government and while because the
chain is so opaque it is hard to know
what exactly was sold or what the
government did with it the app's users
were understandably pretty alarmed
feeling disturbed
appalled
but not surprised sarah mustafa used
muslim pro that app has since reportedly
severed ties with its data partners so
intrusive you know my conversation with
god
is not information that the government
needs
yeah of course it's not information the
government needs there is a reason the
book wasn't called are you there god
it's me margaret and homeland security's
on the line as well hope that's cool
so to recap here we've got shady data
brokers with virtually no oversight
collecting your data and building
profiles that can track who you are
where you are and what you are most
likely to do or buy you cannot edit this
dossier and others from cops to
reporters to your own abusers can find
and use this information it's not a
great situation
so what do we do well it is a bit tricky
especially given the fact that the
entire economy of the internet right now
is basically built on this practice all
the free stuff that you take for granted
online is only free because you are the
product they make money by selling your
data but experts say that there are
actually some small steps that you can
personally take you can use web browsers
like these to help better protect you
against third-party tracking and if you
have an iphone you can go to the privacy
menu hit the tracking button and turn
off allow apps to request to track but
this should not be your responsibility
your privacy should be the default
setting here and there should be legal
fixes to this other countries have
actually tried the eu passed a law to
force sites to disclose cookies and
allow you to opt out but i will say
companies now often cleverly present
those options in the most annoying way
possible with accept all cookies and
easy default but if you want to reject
them forcing you to go through multiple
confusing steps for no clear reason
which is very smart to be honest no one
is going to put in the work to reject
cookies just to sneak a peek at an
article titled five times andrew
garfield's just was
you'd much rather just hit accept and
enjoy your remaining time on this earth
gazing at the most emotionally connected
spider-man to ever splooge the ooze
now
as for here in the u.s individual states
have tried to limit data brokers but
advocates say that what is really needed
is a comprehensive federal privacy law
governing them this has been proposed
for years now but nothing has happened
for a couple of key reasons first
data brokers spending on lobbying in
2020 rivaled that of facebook and google
but also politicians now famously build
their campaigns on data obtained from
brokers both parties regularly boast
about how much they use data in fact
just listen to former rnc chair reince
priebus openly bragging about it
everything about almost every potential
voter in georgia is known and it's not
even a joke they they know what beer
they drink what car they drive how many
kids they have and all that data is used
to target every single voter in georgia
it's true politicians rely on data to be
able to target our interests with
pinpoint precision although therefore i
do wonder why no presidential candidate
has yet targeted me personally with as
promising to fight for the shower of
morning chunks that i so richly deserve
i google it all the time you would have
my vote instantly
but it is very frustrating that the
people who could do something about data
brokers are so actively incentivized not
to but here is where
we may actually be able to help because
interestingly the one time that congress
has acted quickly to safeguard people's
privacy was in the 1980s when robert
bork was nominated to the supreme court
and a reporter walked into a local video
store and asked the manager whether he
could have a peek at books video rental
history and he got it
as soon as congress realized there was
nothing stopping anyone from retrieving
their video rental records too they
freaked the [ __ ] out
and lo and behold the video privacy
protection act was passed with quite
deliberate speed
so it seems when congress's own privacy
is at risk they somehow find a way to
act and it also seems like they're not
entirely aware just how easy it is for
anyone and i do mean anyone
to get their personal information which
brings me
to me because
in researching this story we realized
there is any number of perfectly legal
bits of [ __ ] that we could engage in
we could for example
use data brokers to go fishing for
members of congress by creating a
demographic group consisting of men aged
45 and up in a five mile radius of the
u.s capital who had previously visited
sites regarding or searched for terms
including divorce massage hair loss and
midlife crisis we could we could call
that group congress and cabinet and then
target that list with ads that might
attract those men to click like marriage
shouldn't be a prison or can you vote
twice
we could also throw in do you want to
read ted cruz erotic fan fiction
just to see what would happen and if
anyone clicked we'd be able to harvest
even more data from them which we could
then theoretically take steps to
de-anonymize now am i saying
that we're actually going to do that
collect all that raw information and
store it in let's say a manila envelope
somewhere well i am sorry to disappoint
you we are not going to do that
why would we when we have already done
it because
all that raw data
is currently right in here and honestly
this whole exercise was [ __ ] creepy
we ran those three targeted ads this
week in the capitol hill area and to
give you a sense of just how many clicks
we got it was very much not zero
do you want to see more because i do
please come with me because
let's
let's start with the very first hit that
we got it came at 3 35 pm on tuesday
afternoon from around the embassy row
area when a man fitting our demographic
description clicked on the ted cruz ad
meaning that we now have his ip address
and device id and also know that he did
it on an android phone so we could now
take steps to identify him just like we
could with all these others who clicked
on one of our ads in the capitol hill
area this week including at least three
who may have been inside the capitol
building itself
one of whom clicked on the can you vote
twice ad one of whom clicked on the
divorce one and another who clicked on
the ted cruz erotic fanfiction which was
distressingly popular if you're thinking
how on earth is any of this legal i
totally agree with you it shouldn't be
and if you happen to be a legislator who
is feeling a little nervous right now
about whether your information is in
this envelope and you are terrified
about what i might do with it you might
want to channel that worry into making
sure that i can't do anything anyway
sleep well
that's our show thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next week
good night
you